So here are three, fundamental theorems that come out of
all of this work on Nash equilibrium. They're all in
the screen in front of you. I'll read them for
you in case you can't read my handwriting or if
there's some typo you discover that forces me to erase
some words and then write some new ones. Okay, are
we ready? Alright, the first one is, in the n-player pure strategy game,
if elimination of all strictly nominated strategies,
eliminates all but one combination of strategies, then that combination
is in fact the unique Nash equilibrium. So that's, that's what
happened in prisoner's dilemma, we got rid of all but one
option and that option had to be the unique Nash equilibrium.
>> You say, eliminate all of them, do we, is it possible that things
that we couldn't eliminate in one round, we could eliminate in the next round?
>> Yeah it's possible, so in fact, this is done in an
iterated fashion. You get rid of whatever you can eliminate and pretend
they were never there. Because the truth is, no
one would ever choose them. And then with what you
have left, you just do it again. So it
is possible. Although not in any examples that we did.
>> Okay.
>> The second one is and this, both of these I think are kind
of Obvious. They sort of make sense anyway. At least to me. That any nash
equilibrium will survive the iterated elimination of
strictly dominated strategies. In other words if
you get rid of things that are
strictly dominated you will not accidentally get rid
of nash equilibria in the process. And that
makes sense because, if they're strictly dominated then
if you ever end up there, you would
want to leave. And therefore can't be a Nash.
>> And therefore can't be a Nash equilibrium, that's
right. So, those two things sort of make sense I
think. The last one is true but isn't at least
painfully obvious, at least not to me, and that is.
>> If n is finite, that is you have a finite number of players, and for each
of the set of strategies, that set of strategies is
also finite, in other words you're still in a finite game,
then there exists at least one Nash equilibrium which might
involve mixed strategies. So you're saying there's always an Nash equilibrium?
>> Yes, possibly mixed, for any finite gain. So, when you said I
relaxed everything, I didn't actually relax the
requirement that it be a finite gain.
>> Fair enough. But you stopped writing
finite, so it's sort of the same thing.
>> Yeah, I agree. Because why would you play an infinite game?
>> I don't know. Maybe you got a lot of time on you hands.
>> Mm. That would be like an infinite jest. [LAUGH]
>> Okay. So those are the, the main, results here. So, what did we learn?
What we've learned is that with interesting
games. We end up in these weird situations
where we have to figure out how to solve the game and one really nice
concept, is this notion of an equilibrium and
in particular the notion of a Nash equilibrium.
>> Cool.
>> And there you go.